dude i'm gonna kill you oh my god
oh he boxed the ear that is a real
technique by the way
so cool are you in this yes
i am in this all right double in mr
anthony mackey
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
video stick around at the end to see how
you can get a free 30-day trial
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntmen react i am joined by
two sun men
it's crazy i have both aaron tony and
gita silva
gee there are two black panthers on the
couch there are the original black
panther
and like backup black panther you know
but he's also a falcon so he's like a
double duty superhero so it's like okay
like yeah
most of you guys have probably seen
other episodes but if you haven't both
aaron and gee are incredibly
accomplished stunt men they have insight
into this
crazy world of stunts i can't wait to
have you guys kind of break down some
really cool scenes for us let's jump in
let's do it are you in this yes i am in
this all right
double in mr anthony mackey
we actually went out to an actual air
base and they had a giant
plane that they had mackie sort of fly
in on
on wires it was great that's dope it was
pretty practical yeah
hold that oh my god that was dan carter
doubling for
free for gsp
[Applause]
oh man she's amazing i'm so jealous
so jealous he's freaking awesome he was
a rock star for this whole fight
aaron out here beating everybody's butt
so when he got slammed to the ground is
that your push no
that was was being ramped so i i did
make my contact and then when i punched
him they
accelerated him down in the edit which
looked really good so i love that
i love the swag of the sweep into the
punch into the ground that you do
because
it's like it's like oh yeah that's a t
swag right there
so for that did you run and slide on a
board or did you guys do wire
correct both so we they actually set up
a small board
and we had wires that are connected to
my front and back and i was accelerated
and they they also set a hard mark for
our guy so that he doesn't slam his head
into that actual
interesting so he's like on a wire and
then stops him right before the impact
so can sell the impact
exactly he's on what's called a dead man
so quick question yes sir let's say
let's say you're about to
kick a guy as hard as you can yeah do
you jump off a wall with your leg to do
a kick like that
does it actually help you deliver more
power into a kick yes
anthony pettis am i right yep
seen it in the ufc the technique works
have either you guys ever
been knocked out from a stunt yep thank
you a niece
[Laughter]
what did he hit you with bro uh he had
to do the kip
kick that scott atkins is known for
doing and
he smashed my head into the ground of
87-11 and
i got up and didn't know where i was oh
my god that's the classic
what day is it who are you how did i get
here
if anybody says one of those three
things they have a concussion
[Music]
yo this seems crazy this is nuts yeah
they did a lot of
actual practical uh sort of wingsuit
stuff for this too really yeah
were you the one coming up with some of
the choreography in this yes i didn't
want to want to take a
fight coordinator approach on this
because dave mccomber's amazing
and him dan carter justin eaton those
are the guys that were
kind of in charge of the fights but one
stipulation i had is that i
was responsible for falcon's actions
falcon has a base of
taekwondo close quarters combat and
all of his sort of aerial prowess those
are the three things that i try and mesh
i mix the taekwondo in there because
that's something that i do so i was like
i can kick let's go ahead and start
doing more kicks and we didn't get to do
much more kicking till about civil war
that's where we got to start playing
around with the like
scissor kick and all that other stuff so
that's where i really started to really
take on a style for him
it's blade it's the day opening cena
blade
are we doing this yes are we doing this
so i picked this one
because i think it's super iconic i am
so excited i'm so glad you picked this
brush i love
it
oh that guy got worse
and then all this spin around to the
punch-out camera here we go
bruce lee moment
the fully auto like pistols is also such
like a 90s action movie
you're like you'd be out already did a
really really good job because yeah
he actually reloaded twice i think the
reloads are always a chance for more
flair i mean
we made three videos about this
are where the gunfights get interesting
yeah that's him
that's him get him we're gonna jack you
up i love how wesley snipes handles his
katana
technically it's a stiletto because it
is bladed on both both sides
straight thank you
wes was playing around with katana stuff
cauliflower
just blending blending styles and it's
amazing to watch the fight
choreographers play with that stuff
would you say cauliflower what do you
mean by that escrima is the actual
correct term but it's all close
quarters fighting kali is one of those
arts like japanese
sort of judo and jiu jitsu its
practicality
is so applicable that that's why it's
used
so much yeah because you know most film
fighting is
you know this yeah very little film
yeah but there's ways to go ahead and
make that stuff look really good like
everything that that wesley is doing
right now
is being made long technically that
strike wouldn't be way out there it
would be in here but
he knows how to play to camera and it's
funny because some sometimes
i think what happens with people who are
like purists with like
sword or martial arts circle you
wouldn't really do that and you go
you don't really understand camera it's
a movie though and
and if you can understand that you can
have a lot of fun with martial arts
which is a huge obstacle that a lot of
martial artists have to
get over when it comes to being a screen
fighter yes you have to realize that you
don't need to be as fast
you want people to see that you're
actually throwing the punch instead of
it not being
seen
that guy got work too that that ratchet
was not nice on tile in the bathhouse
his head went into the tile there his
head definitely went too it looks like
it's breakaway tile though
it does yeah so i'm hoping that our
coordinator padded him up because he
definitely slammed into that good
oh yeah i would love to see just a
little bit more of an impact i know
right he's he's kind of on the edge of
frame
yeah and then you see his face very
clearly yeah they're like hey double
it's a good double though they gave my
man a good beard though yes
[Laughter]
if someone was wanting to become a
stuntman or stunt woman what martial
arts disciplines would you guys
recommend that they practice
i would say learn like a judo
mainly because you're going to
automatically learn how to fall then you
can go to like traditional i would say
i started off with taekwondo and i would
say boxing because
your first job as a stunt guy and from
my experience is
throwing a right hook getting punched in
the face or in the stomach
having to react to that and then hitting
the ground afterwards you're not going
to do anything more than that
during the next couple of years or not
so just learn how to throw a really good
write down
you know what it's funny yeah we we all
want to do the like flashy stuff but i
didn't do any of the flashy stuff till
like the later half of my
career if you're coming in you're like
oh my god i've got so much potential
good hold on to that but
make sure that you're also able to just
be a good soldier
and you're going to make lots of money
so it's going to be okay
so this is the part of the video where i
usually ask for you guys to leave a
comment but
i'm going to turn over to gee for a
second here because gee what's something
you would like to see more of
i want to see somebody on fire getting
thrown through a window
landing on top of a truck all right if
you know any
movies or tv shows that have that happen
that's a good one that's a great one if
you guys have anything else you'd like
to see
just you know leave a comment
so we've talked about hard boiled a
little bit on the show yeah it's one of
those classics i've been kind of holding
off on
because it's my favorite gunfight movie
of all time yes
so you guys are here we'll look at one
of the best scenes in the film let's do
it
this web work is so good you know this
so some of these guys will be getting
popped by these things makes acting
really easy i know right
oh it hurts oh my god yeah
[Music]
dude i'm gonna kill you oh my gosh is
that a real dude no
he's all wired because yeah oh she's in
the wire to move the dummy yeah
some puppeteering dummies are still used
well we need to bring that back
right stop stop hurting stump people
so many sparks you can see they're
actually uh just covering the same
action with a bunch of different angles
and
just cutting to different moments yeah
what happens in action films if anyone
says let's just run a russian box
it should be something like this because
you don't have a lot of time to do a
bunch of setups
what you don't want to do especially
with the fight scene is do a russian box
why is because your cameras are going to
be in
everybody's way it's like what camera do
i play what are we doing
oh it missed over here for me of course
it missed for you
for that guy
that's so good that guy is in it
my goodness someone put me out now so
you're gonna do a wheelie on a bike and
we're gonna set it on fire you're gonna
be on fire cool
how can you one up this john moon one
ups it in about 15 seconds
yes you have to i remember this oh my
god
i love also like and when you see a lot
of spark it's like this movies these
days it's uh
is there kits it's basically a paintball
gun shooting paintballs but instead of
paint on the inside of the paintball
it's
zirconium and like some other stuff
basically and when it hits it creates a
spark the thing is it's very surface
level you kind of feel like something's
just splashing off the surface and if
you watched here with the car
you'd think those might be circuits i
mean there's a lot of sparks yeah but if
you look closely you see that there's a
hole getting punched in the hood and a
little smoke ring happening
and you don't get that with zerkitz
that is 17 minutes of pure action
so good it's worth mentioning there's
another gunfight scene in this movie
it's like half hour long
on top of this scene yeah and there's
two other gunfight scenes
that are like world-class defining
gunfight scenes that aren't either of
those scenes that we just talked about
this movie is like the best gunfight
movie ever made
yeah yeah i agree
i picked this one because a lot of the
times the audience remembers moments as
an
audience member watching jean claude van
damme movies
you know when he's starting to win the
fight and he has
a list of techniques that he throws that
shows you that he's about to win this
fight
so let's watch this fun little square
off
with a legend bolo young why does he
have a belt and a sash on
don't know but it's cool because it was
cool
oh he jumped off the raft yeah and he's
like come on griffin it's okay get up
it's okay
[Music]
that was a nice front tuck was that
jean-claude jorge has clean front tucks
and every film that we've seen do a
front tug it's super clean
jean-claude cook could really really do
a front deck i never knew that i'm gonna
say yes
i'm gonna give him i'm gonna give it to
him i'm gonna give it to him i don't
know for sure
yo bobo is giving it to him yeah yeah
you seem like
he's shocking him oh he boxed the ear
that is a real
technique by the way if you've ever been
hit in the ear it hurts
kidney shots and box to ears not fun
very disorienting proper techniques that
actually work
and this is when the montages come in oh
yeah
all the training all the training that
you've done up to this point from your
shoulder
remember
he nailed him on that one he was like
that's for hitting me all
during this fight he finally nailed him
[Applause]
he didn't hit him three times everybody
he hit him one time
classic van damme in a lot of his movies
will always do
the shot at least three three times
[Applause]
sans he still couldn't see him the whole
time
mind you remember that he won this fight
blind frank duke's
legend this is apparently like what
really happened yeah oh really
yeah this is based on a true story yeah
this is a this is actually a biography
frank dicks was actually and the the
action consultant on this i believe
wow the kumate is is or was a real real
thing
yeah it was it was actually full contact
karate tournaments where you saw just
styles clashing against one of those
which is really cool
pretend i just jumped down into the
couch i kind of can't right now because
i broke my collarbone a few days ago
so today's sponsor audible will really
help me out in this situation because i
love listening to books and now i have a
lot of time to do that
if if i'm at all sounding strange right
now pain meds
exist for broken collarbones
if you've heard me talk about audible
before it's no surprise that i've got
yet another book to talk to you about
because
come on it's like literally one of my
favorite things called seven eves
by neil stephenson he previously wrote
snow crash if you're familiar with that
book but this one
is amazing the book literally starts
with looking up at the moon and it's
broken into pieces and we're like that's
probably not good
sure enough some scientists run the
numbers and they figure out that all the
debris from the moon is going to hit the
earth in about two years
causing the white rain and that's going
to literally kill everything on the
planet so the first third kind of deals
with all of humanity coming together to
try to send as many people into space as
possible but the great thing about this
is that it's like everything that
they're dealing with is like
real engineering the real actual
technical problems
you would run into if you're trying to
send thousands of people into space
in like less than two years the second
third of the book deals with what
happens when
earth starts dying and everyone's still
in space the last third of the book
is 5000 years later what would that look
like they just launched their newest
plan audible plus
and with that you get full access to
their plus catalog which is filled with
thousands and thousands of originals
audiobooks and podcasts
including ad-free versions of everything
you enjoy listen across devices
like your phone your watch your amazon
alexa alexa
play never gonna give you up
okay if you're at all interested in any
of this i recommend texting corridor
crew to 500 500 or simply go to
audible.com
corridor crew and you will get a free
30-day trial
check out seveneves it's a great book
leave a comment down below let me know
what you thought of having ghee and
aaron tony on the on the couch together
with nico
double the stunt triple the men
aaron gee almost did that backwards
thank you so much
for joining us on this awesome episode i
had a great time there's some
awesome stuff that these guys post their
instagram so first off go check out yi
at gee extra silva we'll have a link
down in the description below a bunch of
great stuff
aaron also posts a bunch of really cool
behind the scenes on his instagram
aaron tony we'll have links in the
description below aaron has a project
he's been working on called project h
and just keep your eye out for it i saw
a little snippet here and it was
sick so yeah to all you guys out there
thank you for watching this show see you
guys in the next one peace